hallo mein name ist lukaku
und ich bin hier zusammen minecraft
zusammen mit mir hallo wo bist du denn
vor allem kann mache ich mein haus
lustig was machen wir heute eigentlich
hier
ich glaube zeigen wir läuten heute
wir legen los mit einer dieser bilic
denn wir haben in diesem sieg heute sage
und schreibe 32 villages 4 des tempels
also fünf dörfer und vier tempel
ich bin ich bin seit neujahr sondern so
ein cooler freund hat jetzt ein penny
bord okay ich habe jetzt mein team und
fahrer zu dir die meinten irgendwie sie
wollten sterben so nah
die bilder sind auch ganz lieb in die
fresse scheiß village oh jetzt kriegt es
ist nicht so wie es aussieht okay also
hier vorne ist quasi erst mal das dorf
auf die untere pforte an falls ihr euch
fragt wo das ist da hinten ist das
wollen wir jetzt mal rechts im bild
schaut da hinten sind wir gerade bei dem
berg gegen focus frontiers halt direkt
dieses dorte vorne sind tempel bzw
pyramide und ich habe hier hinten auch
irgendwo eine gesehen
die ist gerade glaube ich nur irgendwie
weg oder soja dies hat weg die ihren
kaffee also wir haben dieses dorfes an
diesem korridor - 408 80 und 86 und lass
mal kurz in denen in die pyramide
daneben aber diesmal also gut und lage
wenig in die luft wenn man sich die
kisten ist die recht eigentlich nur
schwarz was ist denn da das ist schon
auch noch die platte draufgetreten hier
ist echt nicht zu retten erkenntnis sein
müssen die leute wie wo ist denn es
unter direkt darunter ist ein richtig
netter spruch eigentlich war 25 vs
fleisch fünf eisen 16 knochen und 19
gold das war's das ist schlecht wow
nein ich werde jetzt nicht den typen
traf also freunde da vorne war das erste
ziel sein dorf hier ist die pyramide und
wenn man dann von dem dorf über die
pyramide weiterfliegt haben wir hier
direkt schon ein nächstes dort was
diesmal ein ganz normales dorf ist aber
trotzdem leider noch keine schmiede wo
mein gott das ist
was ist das als wenn ihr so damals eine
bombe eingeschlagen während der haft
wurde irgendwie stadt gebaut haben ist
halt leider keine vorne aber es ist
alles eng beieinander das dorf
man kann von hier bis nach dahin zur
pyramide und zum dorf schauen und man
kann in die richtung auch nochmal zum
nächsten dorf schauen
hast du noch im dorf gesehen nehme ich
habe dich noch mal wiederholen dieses
dorf hat sogar eine schmiede wo brot ist
auch ein teil von dem dorf natürlich
freunde wir haben am anfang gesagt dass
es wirklich fünfter vergeben wird dass
die so nah beieinander sind dich jetzt
tatsächlich auch nicht gedacht komm ich
bin spaß damit im bau ist gestorben
serbe hat sich gerade mal zu einem
anderen ort teleportiert ich komme
einfach mal zu dir eben hier oder waren
wir waren ja schon es gibt jetzt sind
wir tatsächlich bei einem
wir waren geschockt da hinten ließen das
dorf guck mal bei dem dorf ist direkt
der tempel dran dass sie konnten wir das
immer sehr drängt also ich bin jetzt
schon und in der pyramide drin da haben
wir elf gold 17 gold- fünf weisen
8000 17 goldene emerald oder kommt noch
deutlich gold gerade dazu tatsächlich
wir haben auf jeden fall ein ganz guter
ausbeute das sind natürlich jetzt auch
noch ein paar sachen aus den von der
pyramide vorhin mit dabei aber die
pyramide vorhin dabei ich kann nicht
reden heute wieder
ich habe alles geduldet und diesmal war
ein bisschen bessere sachen drin und
jetzt teleportieren uns zum dritten
wüsten dorf noch ein drittes wir waren
schon locker bei 5 husten dörfern ok
seppel hat sich gerade dahinter
wir waren hier schon es gab wirklich
tatsächlich über diesen sieht insgesamt
fünf wüsten dörfer und zwei tempel habe
ich bisher gesehen dass noch einer also
wir haben uns wirklich vorher
koordinaten ausgesucht weil wir die
danach abklappern wollten aber es ist
wirklich alles direkt beieinander dass
wir alles am stück gefunden haben voll
krank so der lud hier drin ist auch
wieder recht normaler lud also ein
bisschen ein bisschen gold aber jetzt
auch nicht großartig diamanten oder
irgendwie sowas und hier drunter haben
wir natürlich ganz normal ich das gehört
mal wieder dass alles klar ich bin raus
hier vorne ist halt der die pyramide von
vorhin hierhin ist ein dorf und von dem
dorf kann man ja wieder das andere dorf
sehen und so weiter also man sollte das
eigentlich schon alles hinkriegen dass
alles selbst zu finden also bei diesem
dorf waren wir noch nicht näher
wie kann es sein dass sie so generiert
werden das hab ich noch nie gesehen so
halb häuser ich habe ein charakter den
texten dass unser essen was will denn
ihr scharf da vorne und wieder kompakter
einmal schönes granit essen raus und
alles gründlich regeln und will dass
unser tasche ziehe das ist ja unfassbar
auch jetzt provoziert er mich schon
wieder man das was man etwas süßes
richtig durch den sound durchboxen
ein wisent planen wir noch eine vision
haben sich gerade ja der ist hier bei 10
100 360 als loot haben wir diesmal hier
13 gold in der kiste in dieser kiste
sechs gold- und nochmal sechs eisen und
eine rüstung haben wir ein bisschen
bauens und emerald und die haben wir
sogar zwei diamanten diesmal drin dann
würde ich sagen ich weiß gar nicht was
ich sagen soll die heutige folge hatten
über die messlatte was dummheit und
verteilt angeht einfach wieder mal höher
gesteckt und mit den worten da gehe ich
auch hinter schauen
bis zum nächsten